can you comment on what you think this
human capability of imagination that
Einstein spoke about of the artists
following their intuition in this big
Alice in Wonderland world of of uh
imagination what is it
you visit there sometimes what does it
feel like
yeah what does it feel like what what is
it what is it playing but I think all of
us are engaged in that kind of play no
matter when we do what we love I think
it always feels the same but it's not
real right you're so it that you're
describing a feeling but that place you
go to in the imagination right it's it's
bigger than the real world so there is a
big conundrum as to whether mathematics
is invented or discovered
and uh mathematicians are divided on
this
nobody knows where do you bet your money
on
financially
investment advice so let me tell you
something my abuser have evolved okay
when I wrote Love and math I mean I
wrote my book
I was squarely on the side of
mathematics is discovered
what does it mean usually mathematicians
or others who have this you know idea
what a belief are called platonists in
in honor of the great philosopher Plato
who talked about this absolute perfect
forums
so for me you know about 10 years ago
the world of mathematics was this world
of pure forms this beautiful pure forms
which existed outside of space and time
but I was able to connect to it through
my mind
and as it were kind of dive into it and
bring Treasures back into this world
into this space and time
that's how I viewed the process of
mathematical Discovery how nice
the picture also makes you feel
connected to something Divine allows you
this sense of escape from the cruelty
and Injustice of this world you know
which I now recognize in the Divine
world of forms is stable relaxing
something stable it's and in that world
everything is clear-cut yeah it's either
true or false yeah I'm nice very nice oh
my God
allegedly I think now I think now I
understand why I liked it because I
think that I was very dissatisfied with
the with the what we call real the real
world the world around me the cruelty of
the Injustice of it and I I went through
certain experiences as a kid which made
me love mathematics even more as this
place where I could be safe and in
control but you see the human world as
lesser than the mathematical world yes
as more limited than the mathematical
yes yes and I think that
I think that it's still missing the mark
in some sense because
in fact
what I now think it's not it's not a
it's it's a paradoxical the question
whether mathematics is
um invented or discovered whether there
is this world of pure forums and so on
is another paradoxical question which
doesn't have a simple answer
like whether electron is a particle or a
wave
from one point of view yes it's true
and just the fact that so many
mathematicians today actually subscribe
to this idea
gives it the certain credibility because
that's what we feel we do feel that we
dive in to dive into that mindscape so
to speak you know but the very
structured Minds keep where you know I
wrote in the love and math that um
you know the Enchanted Gardens of
platonic reality you know so where all
this fruit uh is grows you know and then
we we might think it gives you this sort
of romantic sense of an explorer and um
someone may be stuck in a you know some
provincial town in Russia for instance
but have the sense of Magellan you know
of traveling around the world it's just
not in the world that we usually think
of
so it's it's one point of view but the
other point of view is that yes it is a
human process of course it is I mean it
is you cannot deny that it's human
beings who have so far discovered new
mathematics and I do not deny the
possibility that a computer programs
will be able to discover new mathematics
but so far it's been humans so it
whatever it is uh whether it's
discovered or invented it is a human
activity what that the possibility that
paradoxes are actually fundamental right
to reality right and really really
internalizing that that we exist in a
world of not forms but of paradoxes
Bingo and so it's like what I said what
the world but if you think it's weird
and I agree with you as a recovering uh
addict to knowledge yeah you know but I
am liking it more and more because
there's so much freedom in it
uh and like like Niels Bohr said you
know I quoted that earlier
the the opposite of a great truth is
another great truth he's pointing out to
this fact that
you know and he also said that some some
things in quantum physics are so
complicated the only way you can speak
of them is in poetry
so in other words what is it about
poetry what is about art why are we so
drawn to that why are we so captivated
captivated by by those forms of by they
are not intellectual necessarily they
are not when you look at the painting
that you like when you listen to music
that you love you get lost in it you get
absorbed in it it makes it make you cry
it can make you laugh it can make you
remember something it can make you feel
more confident or can make you feel sad
or happy and so on what is this all
about is it really is just some play
between some kind of like cellophane
play or some neurons or hitting on each
other is it really that only maybe it
could be it could be both I'm just
worried about kids these days that might
live in a world of paradoxes you know if
there's no God everything is possible I
mean I just they'll have a little too
much fun and we have to put a constraint
have you looked at the world lately I
haven't checked in in a while you you
think it's perfect it's the way it is
now the world without paradoxes the
world and which we believe that every
end every question can be answered
as yes or no that it is this or that and
if you disagree with me you're my enemy
wouldn't that be interesting if this
21st century is a transition into
singing the world as a world of
paradoxes I'm telling you you know
people predicted that you know the age
of Aquarius you know that the access of
the of the Earth is rotating uh relative
to the plane in which the earth goes
around the sun and the period of this
revolution is around 2000 years
so there is a traditional uh way of
measuring that by this
eras you know the the ages so the
previous one is called the age of Pisces
because of the constellation of vices
that it points to so to speak you know
and now it's it's you know as in famous
musical hair they said the age of
Aquarius is upon us
so the different people dated
differently but
um some somewhere around the time where
we are finding ourselves how interesting
right is all the strife and all them
difficulties the world is experiencing
this might actually be the transition to
something more harmonious wouldn't it be
nice it's also interesting that people
from long ago are able to predict
certain things it's uh
and it's almost like from long ago and
you've talked about this with uh with uh
uh Pythagoras
that
it seems that they they had a deep sense
of truth that's right for me is all of
this even even now so it's not just a
linear trajectory of an expanding
knowledge there's a deep truth that
permeates the whole thing yes so that's
how I see it actually I you know I gave
a talk about Pythagoras and pythagoreans
just a few weeks ago at the Commonwealth
Club of California in San Francisco
and because of that I did a kind of a
deep dive into the subject and I I I
learned that I actually totally
misunderstood Pythagoras and
pythagoreans that they were much deeper
than I thought
because you know most of us remember
Pythagoras from the from the Pythagoras
Theorem about the right triangles
we also know that pythagoreans were
instrumental in introducing uh the
tuning system for the musical scale
the the famous
perfect fifth three halves of the uh for
the for the for the G for the soul
compared to the frequency of of Doha or
C you know and so but actually they were
much more interesting so for them
numbers were not just clerical devices
you know that not kind of thing that you
would use in accounting only
they were imbued with with the Divine
and I cannot I cannot say that I I think
we lost it at least I have lost it I
look at numbers
and I don't really see that
the Divine the Divine that they clearly
did and so that
why else you know how else would you
explain so that in other words Divine is
of course is a term which is you know
it's a bit loaded so it's hard to escape
that let's just say something that more
from the
world of imagination and intuition than
from the world of knowledge let's just
put this way
they were able to Divine okay let's
track that to intuitive
to Intuit that the the planets were not
revolving and the Sun and the planets
were not revolving around the earth they
were the first ones
at least in the western culture as far
as I know and in fact Copernicus
gave credit to pythagoreans as being his
predecessors
they did not quite have the the
Copernicus model was the sun in the
middle they had what they call the
central fire in the middle and all the
planets and the Sun were revolving
around
oh around the central fire or Earth they
called it Earth
so but still what the departure from the
Dogma
from the knowledge of the era that the
Earth was at the center so how could
they come up with this idea
the reason was in my opinion that for
them the most movement of celestial
bodies was like music in fact we call it
musical universalis or Music of the
Spheres
for them the universe was this infinite
Symphony
in which every being you know humans
animals but as well as the Earth and
other celestial bodies
were moving in harmony
like different notes of different
instruments in a symphony and so they
apply the same reasoning to the you know
the cosmological
model as they apply to the their model
of music
and from that perspective they could see
things
deeper than their contemporaries you see
so in other words they saw mathematics
as a tool
but that tool was not limited to itself
and it was they always they always knew
that there is more and they knew also
that every every pattern that you detect
it's finite but the world is infinite
they actually accepted Infinity they
believed that Infinity is real
and if you discern a pattern
great you can play with it and you can
use that it gives you certain lens
through which to see
um the world in a particular way which
could be beneficial for you to to learn
more and so on but they never had the
illusion that that was the final word
that they always knew that it's not the
whole thing so there is more there are
more sophisticated patterns that could
be discovered using mathematics or
otherwise
and I think that what happened was we
kind of lost this this other side of
their teachings we we took their numbers
and they're like idea that you could use
mathematics to discern patterns and to
find regularities and to explain things
about the world
we took that and we ran with it and we
kind of dropped the other idea that in
fact
there is a there is another side to it
which is kind of to us now
we say oh that's mystical but
what does it mean mystical if it is
something that helps you to make great
discoveries and the interesting thing is
that the people who are in touch with
the mystical
Among Us
often seen as mad
and many of them are most of them are
well but not all of them all of them we
mentioned Neil spooler and Newton and
Albert Einstein so but that's where the
conundrum is how do you find the balance
between the two so
the point I'm trying to make and you
know and this is what I feel
you know if you ask me what I find most
important today today like what makes me
excited and enthusiastic and
passionate
is this idea
of balance
so you know
um
Nietzsche had this book wrote this book
in the 19th century called the birth of
strategy
and he presented this
Theory which I think is kind of very
useful
of these two sides of a human one that
comes from god Apollo
and that's our left brain so to speak
proverbal left brain so it's everything
has to do with that has to do with logic
and reason and analyzing dissecting
conceptualizing
and the other side which
comes from God the anesis the anisis
and that's responsible for intuition
imagination love
Dennis was also god of wine so it's also
that side of
human that makes us
sing and engage in in you know revelry
and
um and and drink wine and spend time
with friends and laugh and enjoy it you
know so Nietzsche advocated this point
of view that those were two
complementary sides of every human and
as well as a society
and
the purpose of human life
is to find balance between them
because the math is
both discovered and invented we should
be okay with
having both ideas in our head and living
in the balance for me Apollo is like
math and Dionysus is like love so
Geniuses in modern version is love and
math